foreign
welcome everyone
today we're going to talk about how
Enterprises have been simplifying their
hybrid application environments and
cover some common design patterns and a
customer success story
my name is rohith ramkumar I'm a product
manager at Google cloud and I'm here
with Hal Munsell a senior network
engineer from broadcom
for Icom is one of our early Innovation
Partners on Google cloud and an NCC
customer and we're delighted to have
them here today to share their
experiences with you
from an agenda point of view I'm going
to talk a little bit about how
simplified hybrid environments are being
plot made possible with network
connectivity Center some common design
patterns and then turn it over to how to
cover some of broadcom's hybrid
implementation stories and how they've
leveraged Google Cloud
first I'm going to cover a little bit
about network connectivity Center and
its fundamentals from the very beginning
network connectivity Center was designed
to accelerate an Enterprises digital
transformation Journey from a networking
perspective Enterprises have looked to
build simple scalable networking
practices over cloud and network
connectivity Center delivers exact
exactly that enterprises can now connect
VPN dedicated and partner interconnects
as well as third-party sd-wan routing
Solutions and manage them as though they
were part of a single unified Network
fundamentally bringing the best of all
of those into one place what this really
allows is a customer to avoid having to
manage their Network in Parts on top of
that network connectivity Center is the
only product at Google Cloud that allows
customers to connect non-google networks
together
this could be Branch offices and private
data centers that can now leverage
interconnects to connect to each other
as well
now talking about the connectivity and
design patterns that have been
implemented via network connectivity
Center network connectivity Center has
been in existence for a little over
three quarters now in GA and customers
are beginning to deploy Hub and spoke
architectures fundamentally for their
Simplicity in many cases customers are
looking at the fundamental flows going
across their Cloud networks the
north-south and East-West connections
and have found that network connectivity
Center through its spoking process
allows interconnects and vpns to to
connect into Transit vpcs as well as to
be able to connect third-party routing
or firewalls together representing them
as router appliances and to allow the
firewall to control which projects can
be accessed via on-prem locations and
also how projects or vpcs can be
accessed between each other going
through the the firewall component
itself so fundamentally
it creates an optimal long-term pattern
for many of our customers and a
consistent framework that customers can
use to bring in security and extend
those security patterns for both on
cloud networks as well as on on-prem
networks as well
another key reason customers are
deploying network connectivity Center is
the flexibility of the solution
you can now bring on board third-party
sd-wan or routing Solutions and to be
able to to have them dynamically route
as though they were part of the inherent
Cloud architecture or or fabric as part
of the cloud Network itself and so many
of our customers with core competencies
with specific vendors have really
leveraged the router Appliance
functionality and capability to be able
to connect you know some of the routing
gear that they have on-prem and bring
those closer to Cloud workloads via the
use of the router Appliance spoke in uh
NCC as well
lastly with regards to data transfer
itself
um you know fundamentally customers now
have access to Reliable Global on-demand
connectivity to connect non-google
networks together so as I mentioned this
could be Branch offices or even private
data centers connecting to each other
they leverage Google's Planet scale
Network and leverage a highly reliable
set of Rich entry points in and out of
Google which they can connect to using
dedicated or partner interconnect or
Cloud VPN in order to be able to access
the actual data transfer Network itself
best of all they get to pay for only
what they use and so very similar to how
you may be familiar with the structure
of egress data transfer Works in a very
very similar way I also want to make
mention of the numerous integration
Partners we now have on NCC each of
these Solutions have realized what it
means to bring the best of breed of
their capabilities and truly integrate
them with the Google Cloud Network some
of these Partnerships have been
incredibly important for the large
number of customers that now use our
joint Solutions
now for the most important part of our
session I'd like to bring to screen one
of our most important innovation
Partners to discuss their hybrid
environment and how they've been able to
leverage many of the Google Cloud
components to best meet their needs so
with that Hal take it away
thank you Rohan I'm Holland saw with
Brock common thanks again for inviting
us to speak today about NCC and how
we've integrated it into our Global
Dynamic networking project that we
allows our customers to connect from
anywhere within the left-hand side to
our corporate Networks
so when we saw this product and began to
work with it we immediately grasped that
it had the power to do what we'd been
wanting it to do both on the router
Appliance side and also just in the pure
routing environment that we could
leverage almost immediately and since
day one we've we've begun implementing a
new strategy for delivering our internal
customers that you would see on the left
hand side of the slide these are
broadcom employees using different
services
mostly Google that need access to assets
or networks on the corporate side they
provide both customer services for us
from internal from the cloud and we also
provide services to the cloud from our
internal Network so we needed something
in the middle to kind of make that
happen but do it at a global scale what
we did in our organization is we manage
a global interconnect using what you had
just described vpns on the left
with the ability to talk to our
corporate networks on the right using a
wide variety of connectivity
possibilities
and in this case it can be truly Global
our customers have Global VPC networks
that need to reach the nearest entry
point into our Network on the right hand
side and then we have key strategic
locations that provide that connectivity
using partner interconnect dedicated
interconnect or any of the other
technologies that you had spoken of so
this here allows us to create that mesh
that allows us to deliver things on a
global scale between our internal
customers out in the various systems
they use and our corporate internal
Networks
so in this example we tried to drill in
a little bit more to to give a
kind of a lower level view of what's
happening at the global scale you can
have a customer on the left hand side
well again one of our internal customers
that has a global VPC Network they can
exist in any region they choose within
the middle we've delivered VPN gateways
and routers that exist in every region
in Google so they can select their entry
point into our managed interconnects
within those managed interconnects we
then provide five different ways into
our internal network based on region
some in Asia Europe and America and then
where they deliver those networks to us
from they will select the nearest
Regional data center that you see on the
right hand side and that's more than one
data center on the right hand side that
just represents a kind of a common view
of a data center they're able to access
our corporate Network or data centers
closest to the region where they're
entering from on the left hand side of
the screen
so if we want to dig a little deeper
into that we've kind of put up a
detailed architecture
of how we're deploying it today and a
very simplified set but you can see the
global capabilities of it we are truly
using NCC Hub and spoke we're not using
any other products along with it it's a
100 Google NCC Hub environment on the
left hand side we have our Global
customer with multiple regions
connecting to any of the regional VPN
gateways and Cloud parameters that we
provide and they are able to build those
connections themselves on the left-hand
side it takes no uh interaction from us
to build those and also attach their
spokes to the Hub in the center of the
diagram on the right hand side we manage
the data center connectivity using
partner interconnects dedicated
interconnect and we maintain the cloud
routers on the right hand side and
attach those folks to the NCC hub what
that allows us to do is create a pure
Dynamic routing environment between the
on-prem on the right-hand side and the
customer on the left hand side we'll
take our Global corporate networks the
aggregate networks that we have and
advertise them to the customers on the
left from the data center
that propagates out to every single
customer that's attached to this
architecture and then they receive our
routes dynamically through this on the
left hand side they send us their roots
in a longer format in routes that we
will accept and then we will pick those
up on our side of the connection and
then release them at the nearest data
center for the data center closest to
their Network
and through this we've achieved a global
Dynamic writing architecture strictly
using NCC Hub in this very simplest form
and here in the center there's one VPN
or one VPC Network with no networks and
no firewall rules just simply using the
Hub and spoke architecture for
communication and that's how we're
delivering it today we plan to expand
this a little bit more in the future
with some other products and solutions
but this is where we're at today and
it's providing us what we've been
looking for for a long time and that's
really it's a dynamically root within
Google to our corporate Networks
thank you Hal
um for your candid feedback and a
special note to to broadcom for their
Spirit of co-innovation uh it's always
fascinating to see how these
capabilities are used by our customers
um and I think the they by far the most
important uh voice in uh certainly in in
the lives of a PM uh at Google and
um you know there's a journey ahead uh
with regards to where we are taking uh
sort of our products and support for
digital Transformations that occur uh
All Around the Globe for all of our many
many uh wonderful customers so with that
I want to thank everyone uh for
attending this session I encourage each
of you to think about how some of the
the patterns and use cases that we've
discussed today May apply uh to your
needs and uh you know finally thank you
for for attending uh Google next and I
encourage you to take a look at many of
the other great sessions uh available
um and we hope you you learn a lot thank
you
[Music]